Donald Trump imputado por el
Departamento de Justicia las autoridades
estadounidenses dieron a conocer el acta
de acusación contra el expresidente
dicho documento indica que el también
Magnate enfrenta 37 cargos relativos a
la violación de leyes sobre seguridad
nacional El fiscal encargado del caso
Jack Smith reveló el informe donde se
incluyen los cargos contra Trump y
agregó que nadie está por encima de la
ley
elección al Estado de derecho es un
principio básico del departamento de
justicia y el compromiso de nuestra
nación con el estado de derecho es un
ejemplo para el mundo en este país
tenemos un conjunto de leyes que aplican
para todo el mundo
el ahora precandidato republicano para
los comicios presidenciales de 2024 ha
arremetido en numerosas ocasiones contra
el fiscal Smith llegando a calificarlo
como un psicópata a través de una
publicación en la plataforma Truth
social de la cual Trump es propietario
en el mismo mensaje el expresidente
tilda la actual presidente
estadounidense Joe biden como un
criminal biden ha sido blanco de
críticas en las redes sociales de Trump
que acusa al presidente demócrata de
utilizar al departamento de justicia en
su contra el mandatario estadounidense
ha expresado que no ha hablado sobre
Trump con la cabeza del departamento de
Justicia Mary Garland
presidente biden ha hablado ya con el
fiscal general no he hablado con él en
lo absoluto no voy a hablar con él no
tengo ningún comentario sobre lo
ocurrido tras la revelación del acta
acusadora Trump está citado a comparecer
ante una corte en Miami el martes 13 de
junio